[Música]
en primera plana
carlos cerrado
[Música]
bienvenidos en primera plana esta semana
ponemos el foco en un tema del que
comienza a hablarse mucho la pandemia y
la natalidad cómo va a afectar esta
crisis sanitaria a la población mundial
lo hablamos ya con nuestros invitados
paola martínez infante periodista
independiente bienvenida para hola hola
carlos
mi compañero joel aso co periodista
económico en el diario john a frigio el
bienvenido meses carros y en dúplex
saludo ya maría eugenia cossío zavala
profesora emérito en demografía en la
universidad para ib3 señora costeo
zavala muy buenos días
buenos días voy a contestar a las
preguntas sobre este tema importante
interesante
natalidad y pandemia hoy en primera
plana
la pandemia ha hundido la natalidad
cuando hace ya algo más de un año
comenzaban a decretarse los primeros
confinamientos surgían esas primeras
bromas sobre un eventual baby boom
derivado de quedarse tanto tiempo en
casa pero los datos muestran el efecto
contrario en países como españa una
caída aguda del 20% en el último año
según datos del instituto español de
estadística un patrón que se repite en
la mayoría de los países desarrollados
según los expertos el miedo a un futuro
incierto y las repercusiones económicas
de la crisis serían las principales
razones para este descenso de la
natalidad con qué consecuencias lo vamos
a analizar hoy en primera plana antes
repasemos algunas portadas que nos deja
este asunto diario le figaro aquí en
francia- inquietud ante la bajada de
natalidad en francia la crisis económica
derivada de la sanitaria principal
factor que era internacional lleva este
tema su portada fin de los bebés que se
registra en muchos países desarrollados
citando el caso de eeuu japón dinamarca
o españa también la prensa latina como
el vocero de puerto rico se ha hecho eco
esta preocupación y el diario new york
times en una editorial va aún más lejos
explicando que es una buena noticia que
es algo bueno para el planeta este
descenso y que más que lamentarlo
deberíamos celebrarlo
bueno para ahora al contrario de lo que
pensamos esta crisis no va a dejar
ningún baby boom tienen claro como dice
new york times' que esta sea una buena
noticia para el planeta primero hay que
analizar que el tema del confinamiento
es si bien es cierto el mundo se espera
que era un 'baby boom' las
circunstancias del confinamiento fueron
particulares para todo el mundo había
continuado a trabajar había que
encerrarse en departamentos para que a
veces exiguos etcétera y por supuesto
que la sorpresa hoy día con esos
estudios que salieron recientemente con
la natalidad ha bajado tal vez el 'new
york times' tiene razón es un aspecto y
de alguna manera también hace una
correlación con los antes natalistas en
la cual ellos piensan y su fundamento de
ese movimiento ideológico es que un niño
más es un problema para el medio
ambiente porque aporta 50 como no sé
cuántas toneladas de óxido de carbono yo
no pienso que un niño venga a aportar un
problema más digamos a la planeta sino
que más bien hay que cambiar tal vez el
modelo y el paradigma de cómo vivían
abordamos la cuestión planetaria porque
si bien es cierto la natalidad
y las tasas de natalidad siempre están
ligadas a la cuestión económica y la
reproducción de mujeres que veremos más
tarde
hoy día el tema medioambiental se le
agrega también pero no pienso que un
niño hoy día sea como digamos una buena
noticia el hecho de no traer bebés al
mundo como una buena salud bueno una
buena noticia para el planeta hay que
pensar nuevos modelos hay que pensar las
maneras de consumir
hay que repensar modelos de producción
diferente tal vez repensar el
capitalismo tal cual lo conocemos hoy
día gran gran tema gran tema en
construcción pero es cierto que reúne y
hace una correlación nos antinatalista
hay que tener cuidado con ese o logía
que una biología en extinción y ésta yo
era sacó a un bote pronto buena noticia
o no
espero que no sea una buena noticia y
hay que tener que tomar en cuenta el
hecho de que fue una carta al york
times' no era una posición oficial de
teórico a esa diferencia pero espero que
ese tipo de esa manera de pensar no sea
no sea la verdad porque bueno la
consecuencia era decir bueno hay
abandonamos toda ella y mejorar el
planeta y mejorar nuestra manera de
producir de consumir y todo eso y eso
sería un pensamiento pesimista ella
espero que no entre entremos en ese tipo
de dinámica superado en mi caso no no es
una buena noticia profesora emérita en
demografía mareo genera acoso desde la
universidad para ib3 nos va a ofrecer
algunas claves para entender mejor de lo
que estamos hablando cómo debemos
analizar esta bajada de natalidad no se
puede analizar muy bien porque hay
muchos países que no tienen registres
registros confiables de nacimiento
pero ya sabemos que ha bajado en algunos
países como francia eeuu corea del sur
etcétera
esta reducción no es nueva es una
reducción de largo plazo que empezó
muchísimo antes que la pandemia de ccoo
y 19 porque la pandemia es una situación
de crisis y sabemos los demógrafos que
cuando hay crisis hay reducción de la
fecundidad porque las parejas no quieren
este
no quieren hacer proyectos de
nacimientos tener hijos cuando hay una
crisis pues vayamos a las causas del
fenómeno que citaba la profesora maría
eugenia en un país que siempre ha sido
de alta natalidad en europa por ejemplo
si comparamos con su entorno que es
francia el diario le monde apuntaba que
el miedo a un futuro incierto y las
repercusiones económicas de la crisis
serían las principales razones para este
descenso de la natalidad la
incertidumbre está en el fondo de este
fenómeno totalmente y solamente una
cifra por ejemplo en chile el año pasado
habían 34 mil nacimientos en los dos
primeros meses del año y este año había
27 mil nacimientos y hay una baja
considerable en una de las razones
justamente que esbozan los demógrafos en
chile y en muchos países de américa
latina porque es un fenómeno que se ha
repetido en varios países en argentina
en mexico potencialmente salvo bolivia y
perú que sigue más menos con una tasa
más o menos estable pero la incertumbre
económica es el factor determinante hoy
día por ejemplo en chile existe un dicho
que dice nace un chico trae nace con la
ar que está bajo el brazo que es un
augurio de prosperidad y un augurio de
buena de buena racha económica sin
embargo hoy día con el contexto actual
perdón de una crisis que es pandémica
también porque la crisis económica es
una crisis pandémica mismo tiempo de
actis y sanitaria generó incertidumbre
las parejas y no quieren tener hijos
porque piensan que justamente en un hijo
significa una inversión a largo plazo y
sabemos que también aparte las
consideraciones éticas morales de
satisfacción y de amor y compañía un
hijo es una inversión importante de
manera económica entonces esa
incertidumbre económica que hoy día está
siendo latente en muchos países de
américa latina hace que las personas
piensan la piensan dos veces antes de
proyectarse una batería claro no sé si
hablar de países como españa francia
corea del sur eeuu donde ha bajado la
natalidad estamos centrándonos mucho en
países en un efecto en países
desarrollados
joel en un continente mucho más joven
que es el africano no sé si este
fenómeno sus claves y sus consecuencias
se ven de una forma de una perspectiva
muy distinta distinta y urgentes
el que es baja de natalidad en áfrica
así que bueno son problemas de países
ricos pero al mismo tiempo para
retirarse en el caso del occidente por
un momento pienso que una razón de por
la cual los los políticos y todo eso
están
en el caso de japón por ejemplo que por
ejemplo la edad de las páginas en la
calidad fue algo que ocurrió en 10 años
entre 47 y 56 la estacionalidad fue
divida en dos y nunca regresaron a dar a
los diversión desde antes así que bueno
pienso que la gente está imaginando que
algo así puede suceder en europa y los
eeuu en la mer gallina y sería muy
difícil cambiar este esa dinámica cuando
empieza a durán en áfrica no estamos en
nosotros problemas claro es que las
consecuencias demográficas de esta
pandemia las mediremos por dos variables
el número de muertes y la bajada de la
natalidad hasta ahora sólo hemos tenido
en cuenta la primera variable no hemos
hablado tanto de este tema lógicamente
porque hacemos casi un recuento a diario
de las muertes pero está claro que
cuando estás con la nariz en una crisis
poco tiempo te queda para hacer para
tomar distancia y analizar las cosas a
largo plazo por supuesto que el
principio el abandono en los momentos
más álgidos prodigio hacia la gente era
contar los muertos y cada país se hacía
un índice una
una clasificación según la cantidad de
muertos que había hoy día con un poquito
más de distancia se están viendo los
efectos justamente de esa crisis y el
efecto está ahí la natalidad ha bajado
pero ojo también tiene que ver con lo
que decía materialmente la incertidumbre
económica y en américa latina'
la tarea de la desigualdad es una tarea
que existe de hace mucho tiempo atrás
que había ganar algunos matices de
igualdad a etcétera y con el tema de la
pandemia se vieron agravar estas
dificultades es cierto que hoy día yo
pienso que aún es muy temprano como lo
decía la demógrafa para poder tener unas
cifras exactas y un análisis a largo
plazo de lo que puede pasar más adelante
tal vez unos años más existan vivimos de
nuevo que va a aparecer por nuevas
perspectivas económicas y de visión de
futuro
de las reproducciones de la notaría le
vamos a trasladar justo esto de lo que
habla esta pregunta a nuestra profesora
en demografía maría eugenia ha cosido
a partir de este punto profesora maría
eugenia esto es un paréntesis causado
por la pandemia esta bajada de la
natalidad o es una tendencia más de
largo recorrido que ha venido para
quedarse
primero la pandemia no ha terminado y no
sabemos cuánto va a durar pero con la
crisis y es lo que se ve con los datos
que ya existen
si hay una
una posposición de los nacimientos no
sabemos si eso es
después de una crisis hay un vividor
mucho de la situación económica y social
después de la pandemia
hay dos tipos de sociedades hay hay
sociedades donde hay una libertad para
escoger el número de hijos que quiere la
pareja o la familia y ahí es donde hay
es se observa esta reducción coyuntural
por el cojín pero al revés hay muchos
países donde se han dejado justo por la
pandemia se han dejado de distribuir los
métodos anticonceptivos en grupos de
poblaciones vulnerables y allí hay un
aumento de nacimientos no deseados
pero no sólo eso ha aumentado la
mortalidad materna y la mortalidad
neonatal es decir de los niños justo
antes o justo después del nacimiento
cada profesora maria gener nos cuenta
esas otras variables que hay que tener
en cuenta a la hora de hablar de cómo
los efectos de la natalidad durante esta
pandemia no sé si son más partidarios
ustedes de la teoría del paréntesis o de
una tendencia más a largo plazo
joel quizá a largo plazo lo que con el
plan de distribución que al abandonar yo
pensaba que eran hombres haciendo de
esas proyecciones porque bueno el caso
en los países asiáticos tienen en cuenta
que las mujeres pasan algo como 23 horas
en en las tareas del lugar los hombres
cuatro horas así que en una economía con
cultura la gente irá a ningún sitio
viendo que está esa diferencia
fue aún más larga y no pienso que la
memoria de esos esos meses creo que
puede tener un efecto en el archivo de
largo plazo es una amenaza pinta lo
vamos a seguir hablando de cómo afecta
la natalidad en estos tiempos de
pandemia a vuelta de pausa que en
primera plana está ahora
[Música]
todas las semanas tenemos una cita para
hablar de mujeres en ellas hoy hablamos
de nuestra diversidad nuestros logros y
nuestras luchas constantes aquí
entrevistamos a las que generan el
cambio en el mundo y les contamos sus
historias
[Música]
el día soy en france 24 y france 24
puntocom
el mundo evoluciona cada vez más rápido
las noticias no esperan es por eso que
france24 siempre estará a su lado para
compartir el mundo
para ofrecer la mejor información
internacional 24 horas del día en
cualquier circunstancia france24 en todo
lugar y cada momento con usted
liberté égalité actual y te seguimos en
primera plana hoy hablando de natalidad
en tiempos de pandemia ya saben que la
natalidad ha sufrido una gran bajada en
muchos países sobre todo el mundo
desarrollado como eeuu como francia como
españa lo hacemos con paula martínez
infante periodista independiente joel
asó como periodista económico en el
diario jona freak y en dúplex amario
genia cossio zavala profesora emérita en
demografía bueno hay expertos que
señalan que la causa de no decidirse a
tener un hijo es que en esta crisis
cuesta proyectarse que en cualquier
crisis cuesta proyectas y claro el
ejercicio tener un hijo exige una mirada
a largo plazo porque exige bueno para
empezar un volumen económico pensar
pensar pueden proyectarse a largo plazo
y una crisis impide esa proyección no
desde siempre ha sido el caso por eso
hablamos que la institución de económico
idea frena
estás en natalidad y hay que decirlo
cuando uno piensa tener un hijo tengo
dos en este caso uno piensa y además de
bolsa independiente insisto y sin
considerar las las cosas emocionales y
todo eso hablemos del aspecto puramente
el terrible del frío no en ese aspecto
es cierto tener un hijo traer un hijo al
mundo tiene consideraciones económicas
evidentes sobre todo pensemos en países
de la desigualdad es súper importante
pienso en chile por ejemplo una mujer
que desee traer un hijo al mundo tiene
que sistema de salud que es súper pobre
donde hay que pagar todo cuesta una
fortuna hay que pensar en eso segundo la
educación luego la educación en chile es
altamente es carísima es una de la más
caras del mundo también hay que pensar
en una proyección en una inversión a
futuro entonces por supuesto que en
periodos de crisis económica hoy día y
sobre todo la incertidumbre porque como
bien lo decía la demógrafa aún no
salimos de la pandemia todo es este
hombre pesa sobre la proyección a futuro
no solamente de las parejas porque hay
los matrimonios qué sé yo ese proyecto
inicio y también de las mujeres que
deciden tener solas hijos también
a consideraciones con el que no hay que
olvidar siempre que pensarlo como una
inversión a largo plazo por supuesto y
en los países donde no existen las
condiciones económicas ni de igualdad ni
de paridad ni de con james dean de
posnatal y etcétera que lo hablaremos
más tarde tampoco sea en nuestras
condiciones y las cosas se reducen y la
tasa de natalidad
indudablemente tiende a bajar muy
comentados estos últimos días está
siendo las políticas de china pekín
eliminó en 2016 su política del hijo
único que llevaban en décadas en vigor y
ahora permitirá hasta tres por familia
quizás síntoma de su nivel de desarrollo
estos problemas ahora de natalidad
profesora de marina cossio será
suficiente esta revolución en china para
luchar contra el envejecimiento de su
población
eso tiene que ver en china con la
carencia de mano de obra
el cálculo es en 78 había exceso de
llegada de trabajadores en el mercado
trabajo y ahora como hay mucho
envejecimiento pues hay carencia pero lo
que están proponiendo como multar a los
más ricos si no tienen más de dos hijos
o cosas así todavía los expertos piensan
que es muy difícil de implementar
entonces una política en construcción
los migrantes rurales hacia las ancianas
es de ciudades que van donde hay trabajo
y que se encuentran con muchas
dificultades estos no van a tener más
hijos y además no son los más ricos al
revés
hablamos del caso de china y le quiero
preguntar el periodista económico como
devenir encauzadas las ayudas de un
estado para fomentar la natalidad ahora
que nos vamos a encontrar con estos
problemas en muchos países qué
parámetros qué criterios tienen que
tener unas autoridades para planificar
una buena política de natalidad algo que
llama los costos de oportunidad se habló
del costo de gasto en que muy bien qué
hacer con conciencia a todos los niños
pero las mujeres quieren niños tienen
que abandonar algunas oportunidades
profesionales y eso es algo que la gente
sin hilos
el gobierno y todo tiene que tomar en
cuenta y en muchos casos no lo hacen y
eso es para mí el factor fundamental
para cambiar la dinámica no se puede
hacer una política estatal de tasas de
natalidad digamos si no hoy día
considerar el tema de la paridad
porque si bien si no un estado es un
estado paternalista y decirle del nuevo
dictador de orden tú tienes que
reproducir porque necesitamos más niños
para poder pagar pensiones y mantener la
economía más
es una posición paternalista que
corresponde un patriarcado que hoy día
las mujeres no quieren y eso lo sabemos
muy bien en américa latina por ejemplo
las mujeres son cada vez más decide
horas de su sistema de reproducción y
por esa misma razón la baja insisto la
calidad no solamente una opción que
viene con la pandemia y ya venía
produciéndose desde antes entonces yo
pienso que hoy día es un estado quiere
justamente los busti darles de nuevo una
nuevo aliento digamos la natalidad tiene
que considerar indiscutiblemente la
paridad del crédito política esa visión
estadista tiene que tener una visión de
género y no tratar a la mujer como un
objetivo de ser madre puro y duro' por
supuesto y al mismo tiempo hay que saber
qué día de hecho la baja era tal ya en
américa latina tiene que ver con ese
movimiento también un movimiento
feminista que ha cambiado el paradigma
por algo han surgido movimientos como el
snow mole nomaders o las madres a las
chicas también hoy día 15 20 años y 30
años piensan cuatro o cinco veces
y por supuesto una gran devoción al que
tú mencionadas anteriormente muy
importantes y esa canción también no la
quieren por eso también está la idea la
dicotomía es que el hijo carné
profesional lo maten
considerado es posible pero también
requiere una carga emocional por
supuesto yo pienso que el hecho que hoy
día las mujeres tengan menos hijos y se
proyecten menos en la materia tiene que
ver con ese cambio que surgió hace ya
varios años en la cual la maternidad no
es la causa absoluta ni la razón
absoluta de tu pasaje por la tierra o
extracto digamos
es verdad que el sistema bueno de la
inercia histórica les ha dicho tantas
veces a las mujeres que una mujer no se
realizada hasta que no fuese madre ahora
las nuevas generaciones han quitado eso
de encima por la igualdad porque
lógicamente es mentira una mujer puede
ser también la causa-efecto y la
correlación entre educación y fecundidad
mientras más las mujeres son diplomada
mientras más estudios hacen menos
tendencia tienen a pensar justamente en
la maternidad como una posibilidad
realización y al mismo tiempo existen
evaluaciones horribles como apple o como
facebook en 2014 propositivo proponían
digamos la congelación de óvulos que
siguió haciéndolo por ejemplo para que
las mujeres pudieran conciliar
maternidad y vida profesional siempre la
mujer va a tener esa y este doble
estándar esa doble problemática es que
como el hijo soy madre o soy profesional
entiende entonces en esa perspectiva hay
muchas mujeres hoy día que deciden no
tener hijos y que hay este tipo con
mucha razón digamos porque es una
elección yo decido de mi cuerpo yo
decido que hacer de mi reproducción y
ese movimiento es un movimiento un
cambio para que me quede venía operando
excitada
asistimos que las mujeres se apropian de
su aparato reproductivo supuesto quién
quién eres tu estado o quien sea para
decidir que yo tengo que tener bebés
desierto para poder alimentar que
economía digamos yo él
en el estado interviniendo en decisiones
de familiar de niños y todo eso porque
en la historia siempre el resultado
fueron fueron pésimos
casi siempre así que esas son decisiones
individuales lo que les puede hacer es
facilitar la decisión es decir queridos
chicos eso viene con diferentes
diferentes al sistema para incentivar la
gente hacia rupert es crear el clima y
crear el clima para que esa decisión sea
lo más libre posible dentro de ir a ser
lo más absolutamente libre posible lo
sabemos pero insisto lo que lógicamente
y políticas que van contra esa libertad
por ejemplo entregaron los cheques
entregar una persona un cheque-bebé no
parece que sea la mejor política porque
no afecta igual a una clase rica que es
una clase pobre y de hecho zapatero
cuando lo propuso
no funcionó efectivamente y no tuvo el
efecto que ellos deseaban porque insisto
hay un cambio de mentalidad hoy día las
mujeres tiene un empoderamiento que va
más allá del hecho de realizarse a
través del hecho de ser madre
independiente que el estado te ponga
todas las garantías
siempre hay una una separación y una
diferencia una brecha importante entre
una política una programación de la ley
y en la aceptación y en la aplicación de
esa ley pensemos en el posnatal por
ejemplo en muchos países por natal
existe son avances sociales importantes
pero hay uno por ciento de los hombres
que lo toman entiendes entonces que
siempre pensarlo desde ese punto de
vista el estado propone cosas o que hay
leyes que dan cuenta de una evolución
social de un de un cambio de mentalidad
etcétera pero después hay que ver como
la sociedad como los hombres también
insisto a los hombres no es una postura
mente femenina la reproducción
hablémoslo claramente hay mucho más
explicación de trompas y vasectomía en
el mundo y eso es una constatación
entonces la paridad tiene que estar en
el centro de salud francisco en tantas
le quiero preguntar a la profesora
marion general cossío la misma pregunta
con la que nosotros arrancamos el
programa es realmente una mala noticia
este descenso de natalidad
t
hay diferentes aspectos en esa pregunta
la preocupación por la baja de la
natalidad es por el envejecimiento de la
población y la falta de atención a la
población envejecida por muchos países
que no tienen las políticas sociales de
pensiones o de atención a la salud
adecuada
y se señala mucho el perjuicio contra
las mujeres porque ellas son las
encargadas de atender a los abuelitos ya
las personas de mayor edad entonces
cuando hay buenas políticas sociales y
que hay libertad de escoger el número de
hijos que se quiere hay una hay una
propensión a tener familias pequeñas
para las poblaciones que tienen mejores
condiciones de vida donde ha habido
mucha
mucha esperanza por la educación el
estudio de las mujeres condiciones de
trabajo femenino de buena calidad y
políticas que acompañan esa inserción de
las mujeres en el mercado de trabajo y
además a nivel familiar donde hay es
family libre es decir acompañamiento
para el embarazo la maternidad y la
paternidad
políticas que acompañan a las mujeres a
visión de género al que se refería a
mario gen a que la nombrada también mi
compañera paola antes quizá por ejemplo
podemos decir yo el que escandinavia ha
sido un buen ejemplo en los últimos años
en esa crear esas condiciones sí porque
es un sistema completo no son solamente
el cheque o un cheque violencia que bebe
no son solamente a incitaciones ligar es
para crear más oportunidades es un
sistema completo en el que los hombres
se toman sus días de baja parental en el
que claro está el estado la sociedad y
las empresas todos tienen un interés en
que el sistema funcione así que bueno si
funciona recordemos que durante la
pandemia habíamos hablado asumo
emisiones atrás sobre la dificultad de
las mujeres porque su trabajo es
aviación muy precarizado durante la
pandemia y quieren las principales
afectadas principalmente en américa
latina y también en áfrica y también hay
que considerar eso es cierto que los
sistemas y nórdicos por ejemplo hay un
sistema social que es global aunque
influye que o sea que tiene una que
abarca todos los aspectos de la sociedad
tanto de las tasas de natalidad como
empresas y compañías aquí tal vez tomar
como ejemplo siempre siempre es normal
como ejemplo pero después de llevar las
cosas a la materialidad de nuestras
realidades latinoamericanas dispares y
super desiguales también es más complejo
pero insisto que hoy día es una
oportunidad para los estados de pensar
en paridad me quedo ya sin tiempo
muchísimas gracias a los tres ha sido un
placer ya ven que teman tan complicado
con tantas aristas que el que hemos
tratado hoy en primera plana hasta la
próxima semana muchas gracias